you said like you know people in the FBI
is just following the law but there's a
chain of command and so on uh what do
you think about the conspiracy theories
that people some small number of people
inside the FBI conspired to undermine
the presidency of Donald Trump
if you were to ask me when I was inside
and before all this happened I would say
it never happened I don't believe in
conspiracies you know there's too many
people involved that somebody's going to
come out with some sort of information
but I mean from the more the stuff that
comes out it's surprising that you know
agents are being fired because of
certain actions they're taken inside
um and being dismissed because of
politically motivated actions
so do you think it's explicit or just
pressure just do you think there could
exist just pressure at the higher ups
that has a political leaning and you
kind of maybe don't explicitly order any
kind of thing but just kind of pressure
people to lean one way or the other and
and then create a culture that leans one
way or the other based on political
leanings you would really really hope
not but I mean that's seems to be the
narrative that's being written
but when you were operating you didn't
feel that pressure
man I was just a low level you know I
had no aspirations of being a boss I
wanted to be a case agent my entire life
she loved the puzzle of it by the the
chase I love solving things yeah yeah to
be management and manage people and all
that and like no desire whatsoever